[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
ja mein name ist die basstöne künstlerin
ich finde mehr oder weniger unter
ausschluss vor publikum statt und darum
passt das wunderbar ich darf jetzt ganz
exklusiv ist landesmuseum ausstellung
mit rat und kommission persönlich wie
vor von der kuratorin ist wissen
privileg und ich mich sehr freue
[Musik]
- christine kano ich bin
kunsthistorikerin und kuratorin am
landesmuseum zürich und die letzte
ausstellung realisiert habe ich muss
ständig übernommen mittelalter wenige
tage vor eröffnung hand museum schließen
und peter merz und umso mehr freut uns
dass man ein gast der von den formel
dass man die auch ständig dürfe publikum
gezeigt dass mit merkel
ich nehme jetzt sogar aus höflichkeit
umfrage gerade wo ist
desinfektionsmittel katholische viele
marin hunt und sich beweisen
man müsste eigentlich nur noch fünf
jahre wurde vom papst
[Musik]
sie fördert wieso man dank das
kontaktbüro zugang mamadou ständig habe
gerade vor wie oft habt das sind doch
gute die kirche veranstalten sind
fotografien vertrauen in die strom- und
seinem übergangs oder modernen ideen ins
mittelalter machten diese herzen trauen
als aber jungfrau wird als karte
verschlossenen betreiben
das ist das wichtigste formations moment
für mich ich meine penetrieren jetzt die
jungfräuliche ausstellung oder diese
maschine jungfräulichen aus als die
meisten
[Musik]
und was die stars des teams wies aber
mit zwölf jünger und es war sein kopf
los und holt maria ja das ist ein wenig
an darstellung von aber mal aber es ist
variiert stark stellt und maria ist
natürlich jedem frei wortlos stück und
vor allem wie danone ist das natürlich
die zentrale figur in maria ich das
vorbild ideal nicht finden
[Musik]
nun an den grossen politischen man ja
also ohne politische macht die
theologisch politische macht denn sehen
sie aber jetzt das beispiel hat welt von
mexiko ziehen sich als starttermin xii
sie ist sind sie am fenster in theorie
535 gesagt und auch als bauherrin
fungiert wird heutige münsterplatz so
alle gewinner ist die sehr bedeutende
und einflussreich und achsen
persönlichkeit gesehen also seine
karrierechance und wenn man aber eine
musik geboten sieht dass man keinen aber
es ist nicht total vor frauenklöster
nahtlos in eine ordentliche stifter und
und die adlige familie
denen ist es natürlich wichtig sei dass
die richterin die in die großstadt
platini fluss bergen frost macht
überarbeitet und im orient gedanke toten
gedankt und den quasi denn den fünf
familien shooter war cool fand eine gm
bietet für familien ausgepackt von
renault nicht wirksam stieg sie also
wirksam ist geplant
wieso die jungfräuliche braut christi
gesehen und als braut christi am
werkstück im begonnen und gott am
nächsten gestanden und direkte
vermittlerin
[Musik]
sind denn die wirkliche jungfräulich sie
am anfang sind doch die die rutschten 2
max wiedemann als hätte die junge frau
egal wo das jungfräulich sie klappt hat
das ist es wirklich als ideales ziel für
den vielen seiten
das war nicht so klappt dann doppelt
löscht aber möglich und nun ein konvent
internet ist das ist in sicherer kontakt
gar sexuelle kontakte mit billigung oder
oder genötigt das in den andreasmarkt
erarbeitet aber einige sogar von einer
frauen jetzt also deinen porträtiert und
hätte sogar im kader
ja und zwar die kleine katharina von
siena und dass ich die letzte vom
prinzen vor der hochmössinger
reformation und sie hat also man hätte
größten acht reformation hätte ist groß
doch wünscht und der stadtrat und den
piloten wie viele linien und hätten mit
40 über 42 kinder kann diese apparate
herbstein historikerin der user gefunden
aufgrund vor urkunde
dass katharina von simon nur während
ihrer amtszeit als kind geboren tochter
[Musik]
in den städten aber nicht ran oder wofür
die maschine hatte der guard von lingen
als eine wahrscheinliche was nicht
nachhaltig bekannt ist wieso eigentlich
hildegard von bingen kennt man kennt in
die dritte und jedes benutzt für viele
naturheilmittel hildegard von bingen ist
halt sehr früher hätte mit ihren
visionen schriften aufsehen erregt also
die sind hoch der acht hochgeachtet er
als kind so wie sie ohne curtis visionen
noch wenige gnaden erlebnis das ihn
niedergeschrieben hochkomplexe schriften
damit bild für bild & text und musik das
ist eine einheit und zum bekannten
kompositionen geschrieben wo nachhaltig
sind wo man erhöht musik nach erkennt
naturheilkunde sie besingen
herbstaktionen machen wir das haus
verlassen
[Musik]
was ich dann geht es dann irgendein
manager der botschaft und man sieht dass
man in der oberstufe lehrlings sie wenn
ich jetzt meine mädels also gut dass ich
eine fordern erste info einzylinder sie
und messages kommen aber das internet
präsentieren will ich dass das kosmos
also dass das göttliche und menschliche
und und die irdische kräfte und die
göttliche kraft dass das 1 1 ist
ganzheitlich das ganze also liebe frau
aktuell ja
[Musik]
damit oft also ein beweggrund überhaupt
für vertrauens werde
dass man aber den nicht direkt oder
nicht die ganze zeit nur normal ist oder
um die der familie muss gewähren muss
sexuell zur verfügung stehe ja das ist
natürlich mein im mittelalter war sie
ist schon heraus fällt weg sind und
wieder geschafft und wieder geschafft
den geburt das sind natürlich hoch
risiko aktives kind und wird mutter den
gr stereo vom kind sehr viele sind
gestorben hoch die
kindersterblichkeitsrate also muss ich
immer große risiko verbunden
und dann natürlich in ein kloster
menschen sagt sie man hat ein kleines
dach über dem kopf
insofern geschützt gesehen und ich finde
ich erstaunlich wenn man 70 70 oder die
hildegard von bingen sogar 80 wird und
das ist in der tat ist das natürlich
rollt also das zeigt dass die frauen
anders laufen können für wie viele in
der stadt auf dem land was ist ein
attraktiver als einem
hochmittelalterliche frau zu frau aber
durchaus mit mit besitz und medien statt
oder sie unterschiedlicher innerhalb von
kloster karriere machen so als ob die
sind sicher hat man eben ein großer sehr
viele möglichkeiten hätte dass er nicht
nur mit dem die single hat es sehr viele
amt geht damit die praktik mannschaft
funktioniert also die schaffnerin die
kellnerin das betriebswirtschaftliche
logan dass die namensgeber stimme
also es ist sicher ganz andere teil hab
gesehen mit dem im bienenstock und
einfach ganz ohne druck oder zitrone und
essig in organisations- und dass eben
diese funktioniert und es ist die
dynamik
so eine gemeinschaft wie eine familie
oder wenn wir bestimmt worden ich gerade
in einer familie war wo sich eine tür
oder muss ich jetzt muss ich aber was
habe ich jetzt tun kann ist man
natürlich in der großstadt zwar in oben
und in der lostrommel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie löst die haben ihre lieblings
heiligen mumifizierte hatte tim k oder
soja unbedingt dass noch nichts aber
einfach noch immer im kopf religion ich
oft es in bestandteil von der stadt
gesehen oder das hoch und die sind den
vorschlag sieht da hat es glas verfolger
sg stahl glas damit die gläubiger denen
die religion an keine anlagen und und
dann wirklich gedacht berichtet der
heiligen ursula das spielerlebnis in
köln sind hunderte in glee kopf elite
auf montag standen hüttner und ob es vor
allem kopf denn so viele knochensplitter
die wirklichkeit und gibt das ich aus
tiefen das licht aus bergen und im
gesicht zuzog wird fleißig hat das
innovative idee ausgesehen
[Musik]
begeistert haben ihr wunderbares lag das
vieh ist eine moderne halle
50 years of royal so drastisch muss man
sich das im mittelalter nicht vorstellen
aber die ganze sind 1800 jahrhunderten
museum in colmar und entsprechen dem
mittelalter brauchen frauen lösten die
elfstellige sich dominikanerin sie im
kloster bachit theorie und die zeigt
sich da war mit mehr glück als witz und
liebe geiseln in der hand und mit
aufstellen können so mittelalter wie
sich nun dagegen sieht die geisel und
wie sie sich selber geißler
es ist schon daran dass man der mit
schwester schwach zu oft aber das macht
ist dass ich alles in allem die
passionsgeschichte und der zusammenhang
mit einer passionsmusik sein hätte geist
wie jesus mit punkten das maß und sofern
dieses nach hat empfinde das ganze
geißler ist chance sieht dass man mit
schwester versenden befreit und den
eigens geißler mit eigenem geistlichkeit
machen die fleischlichen luft unter
bundes also dass ihr antrag auf jeden
fall kriegt das ist noch kein jahr in
los angeles
das geht wegen h und deine internet
wächst rapide offenbar aber sie haben
spricht er niedergeschrieben sind von
der schwester von nonnen im kloster dass
sie besonders aus kleid drei tagen das
sie neues kleid mit nägeln schwarz
spüren also dass sich schmerzen zufügen
ist in der tat ein wichtiger bestandteil
sie hätten der askese und am frühen
abend fiel ans klavier kann oder will
ich das
einsatzraum solide zum sich
wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
also wenn ich jetzt dort wird besonders
gefäß entwendet oder oder ist das media
ist ein die ich da rein materiell
überhaupt das ist gold schauen und gold
die ganze herstellungsqualität vor dem
produkt und dann ist natürlich ein brite
lee werde die ganze geschichte oder
hinterstoder wenig konkret
konkrete zahlen des übrigen sinne war
hunderte sich fragen was ist bestimmt
die verträumt lag sie vorn am altar
führen
wie wird ihr zum zum bluetooth anbieten
blick und brot
[Musik]
nein
fans finden wieder einzeln aber das ist
etwas anderes zur mittelstation richtig
doch noch einen finde aber dass die
dinosaurier sind dann das einfach
mittelalterliche hektische dieses mal
vor phobie als gestört ich oder wie man
sich das vorstellen
magersüchtige den dixie und verzicht auf
überfluss mit dem talk die
bescheidenheit das ist nicht viel mehr
freunde ritten im luxus dass es in c
entspricht natürlich hatten glück solche
idealfall gegen klara von assisi wo
extrem gestiegen also fast so krank dass
finden bezeichnet magersucht aber dass
wir auf seite immer sucht sich
eigentlich wenn eine krankheit von der
modernen will es muss ja überfluss hat
suchen als kritisch sieht das heißt ja
dass im kloster du dich eigentlich
meistens nahrungsmittel sind um mit land
besitzt kommt so wieder in der kultur
und den reglos stadtansicht allerdings
mit karts umso mehr ist das fasten halte
spirituellen gehalt ist ein frommer
gedanke ja da muss ich mit einer maske
konditionen schöne schnappen kann aber
falsch sein therapeut ressourcen große
show aber das ist schon im mittelalter
die eltern hier der weg über costa
mutter gefunden zu haben als beispiel in
alberta 40 interessierten 100 ihnen 240
in alpbach klappt und diesen trauen
andere verhalten ist dort wo viele
menschen getroffen wird
besonders stark treffen infektion sind
handfeste bereit und ist doch ein
tiroler comfort hotel wurden die
vergangen geklagt und das klage einer
sitzt vor der schwester unsicher sind
auch extern über sie plagt hat nach der
geschichte bestimmt sehr schnell können
verbreiten im kloster und es ist
überliefert wie viel innerhalb von vier
monaten 100 sagt seine schwester
gestorben
wo vor über 240 muss der verstellte ja
erstellt und das hätte natürlich einen
abschied vom eine große personelle
verlust ist das natürlich eine
finanzielle folge kommen jetzt viel
besser wegkomme ist er täglich aus dem
kloster angebracht ist und der brust
überliefert die nonnen in engelberg anja
sehr viel so stieg geräte hergestellt
und der bus trotz dass der brust platz
hat mit den kranken und starb und
umgelegt und und so denn die letzte
ölung erteilt wenn es noch ein direkt
die videos schliemann aller ruhe stehen
und das lamm gottes verteile es schön
dass das baby
[Musik]
o
wahrscheinlich google maps ja das ist
google maps vermittel hafteinrichtungen
das was für das kloster das ist groß
doch kleine und grosse klinge dauer in
basel
der strick und tätig das kasernenareal
was jetzt als klosterkirche dargestellt
ist ein wunderbares modell ich liebe das
was besondere namen als passen in
leblich das methan aber wenn wir das
genau orten gesät über nun auf einer
bank sitzt oder wie sie doch egal ob
frisch oder ganz sparen und da hat eine
art schutz bleibt man muss leider nach
ganz die bälle braucht für zum zum zum
seite geißler machen und übrigens ich
dass es ohne sie hätte ich das nie
fehler mit sich zufrieden und durch
klostergarten
es schien dass gar nichts vielmehr muss
da unter klaustrophobie dass das
gartengelände quasi das große halbe
stadt besonders dass ich sehr großes
klosters sie das ist richtig sie in
basel sind hoch liegen und sie also die
haben nur ich habe ein entsprechendes
lager führen beginn stiko und das ist
erste großstadt sie ist klinik
lingenthal dann ist es soweit
damit ist die große klosterkirche
mittelgroße kreuzgang und hindern in
klausur da kann also so die liegenschaft
jetzt erlebt und unterschritt macht die
gegenwart wer wäre denn jetzt die besten
universum magdalena martullo mit mit
großer sitz oder wels jacqueline badran
weisheit alle potter soll die der
allgemeinheit hörer splitter stadt oder
im kanton
ich glaube das allgemeine gemeinschaft
gemeinschaftsgedanke das war die ideale
nummer drei wollte dies sind sich es
hieß es mit blick auf erliegen
bin dann bin ich spielen muss man sich
fragen was ist das würdige sprache
ich meine wo ist eigentlich der
gemeinschaftsgedanke ist immer noch
vordergründig oder man ist gemeinschaft
man wohnt wenn jedes kloster wien nord
wohngemeinschaft xetra das damit
zusammen dass man jetzt zwar schon die
einzelnen teile
aber man ist direkt mannschaft muss
sehen wie es mit verschiedenen
charakteren umgehen will ich eine rolle
passt und wenn dann ist ein lernen mit
menschen und gott und das ist eine der
größten und das ist dann sagt somit grad
futter verschlägt ist heute zum glück
freiwillig und so denke ich jetzt kommt
niemals wiederum profil markt angeht
eher sparen rangehen
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
street los